.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les haricots ca glisse,
il n'en a pas mat.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Quelque chose a changé dans
la façon de nourrir bébé.
Où sont donc passées
les purées?
- On essaie vraiment qu'il mange
le plus comme nous.
- Bien des jeunes parents
adoptent la DME, la
diversification menée par
l'enfant. C'est une méthode qui
introduit les aliments solides
dès que bébé atteint l'âge
de 6 mois. On profite ainsi
du stade de développement où
il veut tout porter à sa bouche.
ANDRÉA LAURENCE TARDIF
maman de Gaël
- On a eu le OK du medecin
aussi, donc on s'est lancé.
Et dès la première journée,
il capotait sur la nourrit
vraiment! Alors, j'ai un peu de
saumon pour toi ici. Pour les
débits, doit être vraiment
meilleur de manger du saumon au
citron que de manger une purée
de chou-fleur un peu fade.
CLÉMENT ALZIARI
papa de Gaël et Léo
- On estime que c'est plus
familial d'avoir ces repas tous
ensemble. C'est lui qui va
décider un peu ce qu'il veut
manger, combien il veut en
manger.
- Même s'ils l'ont fait
avec leur aîné de 4 ans,ils conr
cette approche développée par
une infirmière au Royaume-Uni.
- Il y a des livres qui existent
aussi sur le sujet parce que,
effectivement, on ne peut pas
donner les aliments de n'importe
quelle façon pour prévenir
les risques d'étouffement.
- Je suis en direct
de ma cuisine. On va cuisiner
une recette de mon livre sur
la DME, les croquettes de riz
legumes.
- C'est devenu une tendance
étonnante. La nutritionniste
Sandra Griffin le voit bien dans
les commentaires qu'elle r
lors de ses séances en ligne.
- Marie-Eve, elle nous dit que
quand son entourage voit
la taille du brocoli,
il capote à cause de la grosseur
du morceau. C'est parce qu'oun
bébé de 6 mois, ça ouvre et ça
ferme la main. Donc il faut
des morceaux assez gros.
Entre 9 et 10 mois, il va faire
la pince entre le pouce et
l'index. Donc là, oui, on
pourrait donner
morceaux
- Il faut choisir des aliments
nutritifs, riches en fer,
mais aussi des textures adaptées
aux capacités du poupon.
SANDRA GRIFFIN, "L'alimentation
autonome du bébé", auteure
- On veut que chaque petite
e qu'il mange, ça lui
apporte des nutriments et des
saveurs, des textures.
Donc, on est vraiment dans
le développement du goû
le développement de ses
capacités de manger et de son
intérêt envers les aliments.
- L'âge recommandé pour
introduire les aliments
est passé de 4 à 6 mois dans
le but de prolonger
l'allaitement maternel.
, c'est assez, commence par
ça.
VÉRONIQUE GINGRAS, Département
de nutrition, UdeM chercheuse,
- L'idée c'est q
favorise la poursuite de
l'écoute des signaux de faim
et de rassasiement par l'enfant.
Donc, c'est lui qui va gérer les
quantités qu'il consomme, versus
l'approche où on le nourrit
à la cuillère.
- Professeur en nutrition,que GE
avec sa fille, Rose. Mais la
science n'est pas claire sur les
bénéfices que bien des parents
attribuent déjà
de faire. Les rares études,
par exemple, ne mesurent pas de
bénéfices dans le développement
de la dextérité fine.
- Il y a eu juste deux grosses
études à ce jour sur la DME à
connaissance. Ce qu'on a
démontré c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'effets négatifs.
Donc, il n'y a pas plus de d'ét,
il n'y a pas de risque de
carences alimentaires non plus
chez l'enfant. Ça n'affecte pas
la croissance.
- Depuis quatre ans, les
ergothérapeuthes de l'hôpital
Ste-Justine répondent
aux nombreuses questions de ce
- On a un gain sur la motricité
fine, on a un gain sur
l'exploration sensorielle,
mais en même temps, si les repa,
deux à trois fois par jour,
l'enfant, en même temps, a moins
d'opportunités à manipuler
des jouets. Il fenfantenfantenft
soit en contacts avec des
aliments ou avec des jouets
à l'extérieur du repas,
le développement va se faire
de la même façon. Il n'y a pas
de methode qui est meilleure que
l'autre, ça, je pense que c'est
un message important pour toutdx
parental qui peut convenir
à un et qui peut ne pas convenir
à l'autre.
(cris d'enfant)
- Le bavoir intégral,
c'est un peu un "must".
- Parce que, oui, la méthode
cause certains débordements.
- La pomme, bébé.
- C'est sûr que ca fait un peu
de gaspillage alimentaire.
- Ça, ça rentre au poste.
- En morceaux co
le repas de bébé se termine avec
l'incontournable débarbouillette
et quelques protestations.